- [Instructor] We're told
Alejandro was curious
if sample median was an unbiased estimator
of population median.
He placed ping pong balls
numbered from zero to 32
so I guess that would be
what, 33 ping pong balls
in a drum and mixed them well.
Note that the median of the
population is 16, alright?
The median number of course
yes in that population is 16.
He then took a random sample of five balls
and calculated the median of the sample.
So we have this population of balls.
He takes a, we know the
population parameter.
We know that the population median is 16
but then he starts taking
a sample of five balls
so n equals five and he
calculates a sample median,
sample median,
and then he replaced the balls
and repeated this process
for a total of 50 trials.
His results are summarized
in the dot plot below
where each dot represents
the sample median
from a sample of five balls.
So he does this, he
takes these five balls,
puts them back in then he does it again
then he does it again and
every time he calculates
the sample median for that sample
and he plots that on the dot plot so,
and he will do this for 50 samples
and each dot here represents
that sample statistic
so it shows that four times
we got a sample median,
in four of those 50 samples,
we got a sample median of 20.
In five of those sample medians,
we got a sample median of 10
and so what he ends up
creating with these dots
is really an approximation
of the sampling distribution
of the sample medians.
Now, to judge whether it is a
biased or unbiased estimator
for the population median,
well, actually, pause the video,
see if you can figure that out.
Alright, now let's do this together.
Now, to judge it,
let's think about where the
true population parameter is,
the population median.
It's 16, we know that and
so that is right over here,
the true population parameter.
So if we were dealing with a biased,
a biased estimator for
the population parameter
then as we get that,
our approximation of the
sampling distribution,
we would expect it to be somewhat skewed.
So for example, if the sampling,
if this approximation of
the sampling distribution
looked something like that then we'd say,
okay, that looks like a biased estimator
or if it was looking something like that,
we'd say, okay, that looks
like a biased estimator
but if this approximation
for our sampling distribution
that Alejandro was constructing
where we see that roughly
the same proportion
of the sample statistics came out below
as came out above the true parameter
and it doesn't have to be exact
but it seems roughly the case,
this seems pretty unbiased
and so to answer the question
based on these results,
it does appear that the sample median
is an unbiased estimator
of the population median.